.
THEY'RE USING WHAT THEY HAVE IN
ANTICIPATION OF ADVANCE OF
RUSSIAN FORCES.
IVAN WATSON EXPLAINED TO MY
COLLEAGUE JOHN BERMAN EARLIER.
>> Reporter: THIS IS A VILLAGE
OUTSIDE AND WE'RE GETTING A
SENSE HOW THE LOCAL POPULATION
HAS BEEN MOBILIZED BY RUSSIA'S
INVASION OF UKRAINE.
ALL OF THIS HAS BEEN ERUCTED IN
THE LAST TWO WEEKS AND IT'S ALL
HOMEMADE, JUST CONCRETE BLOCKS,
SPAER TIRES, SANDBAGS, YOU KNOW,
KIND OF METAL REBAR THAT'S BEEN
KIND OF WELDED TOGETHER, NETTING
HERE THAT LOCALS HAVE SEWED
HERE.
AND WE'RE GOING TO SPIN AROUND
AND YOU CAN GET A SENSE OF WHAT
THE GUYS VOLUNTEERING HERE, THEY
HAVE THEIR MOLOTOV COCKTAILS AT
THE READY, AND THIS IS ENTIRELY
A VOLUNTARY EFFORT.
ONE IS A FIREMAN, ONE IS POLICE
OFFICER, ANOTHER IS AN
ELECTRICIAN, AN EXAMPLE OF HOW
THE LOCAL POPULATION HAS
MOBILIZED HERE.
A LOCAL OFFICIAL I TALKED TO, HE
ESTIMATES THAT ABOUT 20% OF A
POPULATION OF MORE THAN 12,000
PEOPLE IN THESE VILLAGES HAVE
GONE INTO THE UKRAINIAN ARMY,
HAVE GONE INTO THE UKRAINIAN
TERRITORIAL DEFENSE.
HE ESTIMATES MAYBE 10% HAVE
FLED, AND THE REST HE SAYS ARE
VERY ACTIVE IN THE VOLUNTEER
EFFORT, IN THE WAR EFFORT.
THAT MEANS PEOPLE WHO HELP OUT
WITH HUMANITARIAN ASSISTANCE
BEING BROUGHT IN FROM EUROPE AND
COLLECTED HERE AND THEN LOADED
INTO OTHER TRUCKS AND SHIPPED
BACK OUT TO FRONT LINE CITIES
WHERE PEOPLE ARE IN SUCH
TREMENDOUS NEED RIGHT NOW.
YOU KNOW, VLADIMIR PUTIN ONE OF
HIS OBJECTIVES BY INVADING
UKRAINE, HE SAID, WAS TO
DEMILITARIZE THIS COUNTRY.
WE'RE SEEING THE EXACT OPPOSITE
RESULT, JOHN, WHICH IS AN ENTIRE
POPULATION BEING MOBILIZED IN
DEFENSEF THEIR HOMELAND.
I WANT TO BRING IN A LOCAL
OFFICIAL I'VE BEEN TALKING TO
HERE WHO IS JUST 23 YEARS OLD.
YOU'VE NOT SEEN GROUND FIGHTING
HERE YET.
ARE YOU READY IF THE RUSSIAN
MILITARY REACHES THIS REGION?
>> YEAH, YOU KNOW, WE ARE READY.
AND IT IS -- THE SITUATION IS
UNITY IN THE UKRAINE POPULATION.
AND HERE WE HAVE 20% OF
MOBILIZED PEOPLE AND TO THE
ARMY, TO THE TERRITORY DEFENSE
AND LOCAL DEFENSE.
>> WHAT KIND OF MESSAGE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO SEND THE REST OF THE
WORLD?
WE WERE SEEING THE AID SENT IN,
FOOD, CLOTHE.
WHAT KIND OF MESSAGE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO SEND FROM YOUR REGION?
>> YOU KNOW, THE HIGHEST PART OF
MY MESSAGE WOULD PLEASE CLOSE
THE SKY.
THIS IS THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
THAT WE NEED BECAUSE HERE ON THE
GROUND WE COULD FIGHT, BUT IN
THE SKY WE NEED TO CLOSE THE
SKY.
>> ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU.
AGAIN, A CALL THAT WE'VE HEARD
FROM THE PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE
FOR A NO-FLY ZONE, WHICH
PRESIDENT BIDEN, OF COURSE, HAS
RULED OUT ARGUING THAT WOULD BE
THE BEGINNING -- THE BEGINNING
OF WORLD WAR 3.
NOW, THIS IS ONE VILLAGE, JOHN.
I DROVE IN FROM MOLDOVA INTO
UKRAINE YESTERDAY, AND
EVERYWHERE ON THE SIDE OF THE
MAIN ROAD YOU SAW SIMILAR
FORTIFICATIONS, SIMI